stop him daddy proposal II mm by
retrieving this early Elmo's not like
this one you don't
hey everybody is Charlie hopefully
you've had a chance to see the Aquaman
movie by now I've already done my post
credit scene video some Easter eggs this
is gonna be my top 10 WTF questions the
movie was a lot of fun as long as you
kind of accept it for like the big Flash
Gordon Adventure cereal that it is like
it does try to have a lot of fun but
they're a couple continuity errors like
a couple big questions that you're left
with that the movie never really answers
in a clear way there'll be new giveaway
stuff at the end of the video and
obviously spoiler warning for what
happens during Aquaman because we'll be
talking about very specific plot beats
so starting with number 10 king or VAX
is the person the Aquaman's mother's
forced to marry that she flees at the
beginning of the movie leading to the
birth of Aquaman as far as they
explained Atlantean technology is about
the same as it is in present day
although they are innovating some
special weapons that's how Black Manta
makes his special comic-book helmet is
because of some of their experimental
tech over the most part when Aquaman's
mother between 20 30 years ago crashes
up on the shore of the lighthouse these
are relatively the same in Atlantis from
a military standpoint we know she was
wearing a special tracking bracelet that
was given to her by king or backs
because ocean master later gives it to
Mira and it becomes a big thing where
they tracked them through the film using
that so why did or VAX wait a couple
years till after Aquaman had been born
to go try and drag her back to Atlantis
because they made it very clear that the
Royal Guard that had come to drag her
back was also there to assassinate
Arthur because he was a threat to king
or faxes line so he just seems a little
weird that they would wait that long
until after all that had happened after
Aquaman had grown up and actually been a
toddler for a long time and learned all
these legends to try and finally kill
him you think they would have tried that
several more times than what you
actually saw during the film 9 why did
Batman or STAR Labs not create any
communication devices for the Justice
League members to keep in touch in times
of great need I understand the director
James Wan was very clear about wanting
to do a very self-contained film so they
weren't ever intending on putting any
Justice League members in it it was just
meant to be a story about Aquaman taking
the throne and
saving the world with the help of
Aquaman's specific characters Atlantean
characters like Mira but realistically
like after all those news broadcasts
there was a big montage where the entire
world is like look at all our warships
in our trash crashing up on the shore
what's going on here it's very clear
that Wonder Woman and Superman would
probably know what's going on
just because Superman senses are so
powerful so he'd be able to hear or see
what's going on in the seafloor see what
ocean masters doing he'd be doing
coastal relief because he's flying
around the world all the time anyway
helping people from natural disasters
Wonder Woman has lived for so long she's
gotten this education she knows all
about Atlanteans so she would instantly
also recognize what's really going on
and probably tried a message Aquaman to
let him know that they were available if
he wanted their help so all you need is
like a small line of dialogue in the
film where Mira says do you want to call
your friends to help you out again with
this and all he has to do is say no I
don't want their help that's all you
have to say the closest they did get was
Mira referencing him fighting
Steppenwolf she doesn't mention any of
the other characters Superman Batman and
Wonder Woman
cyborg the flash 8 this was another big
head scratcher
why did Aquaman act like he had never
met Meera before when she showed up
outside the bar it was pretty clear
during Justice League that they had some
sort of pre-existing relationship even
though they weren't best friends or
anything like that the firstborn beloved
Queen atlanna
wait
please they discussed his mother Mira
gives in the exact same call-to-action
they confirmed that this movie takes
place after the events of Justice League
so it's not like Aquaman's gonna forget
all that in the intervening months since
this all happened even though it kind of
seems like they hate each other in that
clip they definitely know who each other
are Mira very clearly knows who he is
even though he might not know her very
well but there was also a tie in a
guidebook that they released for the
Aquaman movie that had drawings and
diary entries written by a young Aquaman
growing up where he writes about mera
ins Ebel this is like the quote it says
volcko says the king has a family
apparently he has a daughter my age
called mera kind of sort of jealous that
she's down there and I'm up here so it's
very clear that when he was a kid
growing up he knew of Mira's existence
knew her name so why then between
meeting her in Justice League and then
meeting her again on the shore is he
like who are you like he's never seen
her a day before in his life 7 another
big one why did Aquaman say he'd never
been to Atlantis before when he had very
clearly battled Steppenwolf at the site
where the Atlanteans kept their mother
box the only way that statement works I
think is if you assume that he's really
talking about visiting the capital
buildings the royal palace if he's
talking more about never having visited
Atlantis formally in announcing himself
as a prince like when he rides in in the
movie and is like I'm challenging you
for the throne in the Royal Palace like
yes he's never done that before but he
would have never gotten that armor from
mera if he hadn't have visited Atlanta
so he has been to Atlantis in some form
six how did they teach the octopus to
play music at sporting events on command
and understand social context for how
the fight was proceeding and know when
to actually start playing as weird and
funny as that was James 1 explained that
they were doing Topo from the comics
during the Silver Age Aquaman had a
companion called topo that was an
octopus that could play music so they
just wanted to include that in some way
he said that there were various drafts
of the script where there were different
amounts and where topo did different
things and by the time they actually
finished the final cut of the film this
is what his cameo ended up being like
just like a funny brief moment during
this big fight I believe the first time
he ever appeared was adventure comics
and
2:29 in 1956 and i think the story was
Aquaman's undersea partner but it was
part of like a larger compendium with
other stories in that book five Black
Manta has that special submarine that
looks like an actual Manta how
convenient is that they say during the
news broadcast that it was stolen from
the US Navy's a special experimental
stealth submarine so then how is it that
the US Navy and every other armed
services branch in foreign power isn't
spending every dollar they can to try
and track it down or get the help of
someone like Superman that could
probably track it down in less than a
day if you're not familiar with military
spending in real life they spent
billions of dollars developing new
military technology and Congress will
spend months and months and months
poring over those military budgets so if
the military spent a billion dollars
developing some special experimental
piece of technology and it just
disappeared they would not hesitate to
call Superman and say look all the
taxpayers paid for this we just lost it
it's very dangerous please help us find
it technically you could say that they
would call Aquaman because it's a
submarine and Aquaman's domain is
underwater and he could probably find
something just as easily underwater as
Superman could but the whole kick during
the movie is is that Aquaman
doesn't want to have anything to do with
any real responsibility until this
impending war because of ocean master
comes up so--for that's actually a good
point when ocean masters talking to keen
ear is trying to get him to join his war
he talks about the surviving kingdoms of
Atlantis rising again it's time for
Atlantis to rise but he conveniently
does not mention anything about the
commoners living above water again
because presumably if they were
successful and they killed all surface
dwellers even if they stayed near bodies
of water they would still start settling
above-ground but if you notice during
the movie they explained that only the
highborn people like ocean master
Aquaman mera King nearest anyone of
royal blood is able to breathe above
water and below water that's why you see
all the troops that go with Black Manta
wearing special water suits and then
when mera punctures one they have that
joke where he has to dunk his head in
the toilet so that he can breathe again
so even though pollution would go down
really only like a handful of people
would actually benefit from his grand
plan three
so many of the Atlanteans like ocean
master or even King nearest dismissive
about the legend of the hidden see in
the Trident when there are piles and
piles of highborn people that are really
powerful in their own right that tried
and failed to claim the Trident so
thousands of years go by presumably
people who are like Aquaman that are
part of the line of succession want to
claim the Trident but just don't have
his special ability so they can't speak
to the carrot then but the quest for the
Trident is such a big epic thing that
most of Atlantis knows what's going on
because they're tracking them you have
to imagine that the same thing happened
when all these other people went on
their own respective quests to try and
find the Trident so he just seems a
little weird that you have something
that's so special that so many people
are dismissive of when very clearly a
lot of people have been looking for it
for a long time because there is
evidence that it actually does exist to
Aquaman's mother said she'd been trapped
in the hidden sea because only the power
of the Trident would be able to get them
back out of Earth's core but that's
actually not true the Trident power has
nothing to do with piercing through
dimensions she could actually swim
through that barrier anytime she wanted
it just that the barrier was inside the
trench but you remember that she escaped
through the trench to get to the hidden
sea so if she's made it down there
20-plus years ago she could also
probably made it back but number one
even though the end of Aquaman is all
about him embracing his role as king of
Atlantis in the film didn't need a
Shazam post-credits scene or anything
like that because nothing that's
happening during that movie is really
relevant to what's happening during the
Aquaman movie you really kind of needed
a small moment where say like Wonder
Woman is reading a letter or getting a
message from Aquaman just letting her
know what happened I'm king of Atlantis
now you and the other members of the
league are welcome to visit anytime you
want like please come visit me and then
when they do come visit that just
happens to be whatever the next Justice
League movie is or like a brief moment
in the next Justice League movie I think
the reason why they didn't do that is
just because there's so much question
about what Warner Brothers is gonna do
with that particular franchise like
they're just focusing on the stuff that
they've done well so far like Wonder
Woman's good we'll make a Wonder Woman
sequel Aquaman is making all kinds of
money we'll make an Aquaman sequel we're
still planning on making the flash movie
we have a new Shazam movie we have birds
of prey there's the
Rives Batman movie they're just like not
even thinking about the next Justice
League movie yet even though I
definitely think that they will try but
it might not happen for like four or
five years and by that time at least one
or two of the characters will have been
recast so James Wan probably just wanted
to sidestep any potential issues with
that but I really do think it would have
benefitted from a small Wonder Woman tag
we're just like winking at possible
crossover in the future because of all
the characters that I think will still
be around I think Wonder Woman is gonna
be the biggest one and Jason Momoa
himself said that he really wants Wonder
Woman to cross over in his next Aquaman
movie whether or not that actually ends
up happening we'll see so like I said
Aquaman movie a lot of fun as long as
you kind of know what you're getting
into when you go see it like what kind
of movie they're actually shooting for
like big fun fast in the Furious style
film this a lot we could say about the
Aquaman movie but let me know in the
comments what was your biggest WTF
question after you walked out of the
theater and because it's the holidays
we're doing a new round of that IMAX
ticket giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite Aquaman moment on the video
I'll name a new winner when I post a new
DC video there'll be a bunch of really
cool stuff happening in the next couple
of weeks while you wait for everything
click here for all my Aquaman
post-credit scenes and Easter eggs
and click here for my video on the brand
new once upon a Deadpool post-credit
scenes thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]